nestling on the east bank of the nile
nefertiti's capital city covered over 3
000
acres and was home to up to 50 000
people
what is now barren landscape was once
one of the greatest cities in the
ancient world
and from these palaces and temples the
royal couple
ruled over all of egypt
she doesn't appear to be buried here but
does this place hold
clues to the fate of the missing queen
nefertiti is famous today because of
this iconic bust of her
she has one of the most well-known faces
in all of ancient egypt
[Music]
this is about the spot that the bust was
actually found
we're in the house in the workshop of a
sculptor who was probably called fat
mosey
this is where the nefertiti bust was
originally created
it's one version of nefertiti's official
portrait
she may herself have signed off on this
image
but really we have no idea what she
looked like in real life
nefertiti's early life is also still a
mystery
her father was probably i viziere to
pharaoh amman hotep iii
so she would have been brought up in a
royal palace
by the age of just 15 she married amman
hotep's second son
the new pharaoh akanathan and bore him
six daughters
as his queen nefertiti became the most
powerful woman in all of egypt
[Music]
yet nefertiti's ultimate fate remains a
mystery that occupies archaeologists
all over egypt
you